My name is Keith Porcaro and I'm a fellow
at the Berkman Klein Center. The big part
of my work focuses on how legal
norms form and digitizing society and so
that sounds sort of high pie-in-the-sky
type, so the narrower question that I'm
working on here is, how can communities
take control and make decisions
about the data that they're creating and
the data that's being created about them?
So the research question that I'm
working on within that is how can we use
existing vehicles, like trusts, as a way
to first give communities power to be
able to make these decisions and be able
to sort of protect it against uses that
they don't want, but then the other side
of that is once you've given communities
that power, how do you help them
understand sort of what the surface area
of those decisions are and how to
understand what the ramifications of
some of their decisions might be. I kind
of think of it as two sides of a coin so
on the one side of the coin, it's how can we use law to deal with new
technology, to deal with the fact that
increasingly more of our lives are
digital or online, and then the other
side of that is, how can you use
technology to understand how complicated
systems work like law or like anything
else and especially for people who don't
have the time to sort of think about
this professionally. So for somebody who
is you know just facing a legal issue
for the first time, or just finding
out that somebody is doing a census in
their neighborhood, the
expectation that we should have is not
that they should become a lawyer, they
should go to law school, they should
learn about how databases work, but it
should be what can we use,
and what interfaces, what explanations,
what structures can we use to help
people understand enough of the system
to be able to make an informed decision
about how it should work.